multiple players down folks hi guys
Chris waters here with Eric Tay Eric
hello hello how you doing buddy all
right yeah we're back multiple players
took a couple weeks hiatus for e3
extravaganza we're now all exhausted and
really just want to play video games so
here we are multiple playing or
attempting to we're trying to take it on
secret ponchos today Eric what do you
know of this game I know very little
other than the couple minutes that we
discussed before this like a top-down
shooter it's like a multiple player game
obviously it's like to be too mmm it's
in early access it is an early access to
be tues one of the modes and it's one of
the modes that we're having trouble
finding a match for currently it's
pretty wait no I already created on so
it's pretty sparsely populated at this
point at all hours being that it is a
early access thing the developers have
put up sort of when you boot up the game
they've put up a warning saying like hey
maybe we can all just try to meet up at
like three in the afternoon or a it in
the afternoon and never going to be able
to get into matches in but we're off by
about an hour so we've I've been able to
get into a few matches in the previous
hour we're not having super good luck
right here from this screen but we've
got another account I'm firing up to
join hopefully I'll get in there and
then we'll have a match and you'll get
see some secret ponchos but if not we're
gonna call an audible and play a
different game in a few minutes so stick
with us alright so this game secret
ponchos I actually have to play it pax
east two years ago it was and it was
similar a sort of isometric viewpoint
and it's basically like a dual stick
shooter you run around in the Wild West
as various ponch owed outlaws and then
you
issued each other with different guns so
you have chosen I'm trying to get into
yours so we have to uh laptop set up
getting into a lobby together not quite
worky and why we're together but then
like when we started to join it like
split us off into two different games
which makes no sense it's like I'm
looking for a match he has he's just
waiting for one person I don't get it
it's early access these are the trials
and tribulations of early access I think
it's been on early access for maybe two
months now so like when I got to play it
at PAX East two years ago it was sort of
different in scope I think there were
more outlaws than you can sort of
currently choose here but before you
even get into the game you have to
choose which outlaw you are so when you
did your thing which one did you choose
I picked the first guy because we're
just trying to get through it to get to
options so I got so you'll didn't really
peruse them oh no wait what I was just
pressing buttons like a serene I can't
even alright so one of us yet the old
guy he he has like that grizzled
gunslinger look I think he's got a
shotgun and a width I'm gonna try to
join your manager oh I can't we keep
gave him that player guy player the
closest I've seen is review oh I got
three Jared's in this game Oh player
just disappeared great alright i'm
clicking joined game through the steam
hub but yeah again folks slightly low
player populations for secret ponchos at
this current hour in there like early
access stage so we're gonna give it it
like a few more minutes to try to get in
and then we're gonna wit out totally and
play another game and then maybe try at
the end of the stream forcing upon or
something like that we're set a timer
how many minutes no oh i got in their
game all right that time we just gotta
wait we gotta wait it out gonna happen
to me going down
ah there's two people I chose sorry what
if only those two people they leave but
anyways who's your guy your guy looks
cooler than my guy ah it's like read the
kid or something I don't know I he's got
the tool two six-shooters which you can
you know you sort of fire off one two
three four up to 12 shots and then
reload or you can switch the fire mode
and fire them like both at once for a
more powerful double shot so you have a
main weapon and then you have a
secondary weapon in the case of the kid
it's dynamite you just chuck dynamite
explodes in a big area in the case of
your character yeah I believe it's a
bullwhip which you can like disarm if
you hit the your enemy it'll either
disarm and they'll drop their gun and
have to pick it up or hit shots can also
stun so like you can shoot from back and
stun them there's another guy who's like
a civil war a deserter ok we just has
like a huge rifle with a bayonet on the
end of it and so does a lot of damage
but it's pretty slow and then the fourth
one available is the Phantom honcho oh
is that the guy out there kind of look
like to go sleep mask he might actually
have to bowl with I don't know and the
shotgun no it definitely sounds pretty
good yeah i saw i saw him with a
six-shooter that is he he's got the long
long barrel Corey are nice alt enter
this to get a full screen right there
really feel like we tried to search on
our own to though member and it wasn't
really like we got close a couple times
well no so I think cuz you're both
searching from the same office oh yeah
yeah I got a towel it down here no no
what's one this one is for you today
let's just get then just get that I'm
oh yeah thanks nice got a little glisten
it's right there uh expr from the same
office it was causing problems so look
at that look at that here we go you're
like the spm guy you were you're playing
yeah we had our we had a rendezvous how
do you say this Sega Dora poncho wait a
second oil no idea no idea what did I
use this what secadora what is that a
shake-up luck there you go oh man Drake
man Drake cool so a lot of the old man
here you we should show the kid after
this all right we got a sword an S word
we're gonna wear a night network there's
the kid yeah yeah yes a goal way honey
guy mm bold but that's the Phantom
poncho oh no all right here we go so let
me just experiment but I've actually
have not played this character before so
let's see we got I've got a six-shooter
pretty good range on that bad boy I've
also got a nasty knife which I was like
a good throw them yeah can we get out
range no shot pic that it up I'll take
that back you reload or no it's I just
got the one
never wonder why your teammate is there
anything whoops oh there's a Dodge
mechanic your no no he's done go stun
them with a knife thank you oh yeah yeah
yeahs guns real oh oh you got you the
whip wounded I gotta get scape inside oh
you're my teammates heart spawn he's
back he's back where'd they go look at
all this is new use that's got a person
that I'm not playing with you are with
Sega Dora the sake I don't think so yeah
it's not the sort no no was that the bad
guy anyway new use I think your new use
I doubt got the whip that's sig adoro
damn that whip got that rain would I
like to seize that get the long-range
whip oh haha oh good then closing
distance yes espresso the whip can like
it stun I think you can also wound like
you'll see wounded pops up and I'm not
in sure what effect that necessarily
it's like a stomach kind of thing right
maybe is that only with the Navy no
that's you can tell it was doing there
you go I think they the other guy might
at this drugged up shake it off man
you're fine you're back to even those
all know I'm yeah
who's John it looks like five kills to
win cat wait yeah but every time you get
a killer okay we're gonna be your number
two minutes somebody get us some popcorn
cuz I think this one's gonna go for a
while especially with it watch out for
that with the guys just feeding can't
really see that whip situation it's
tough areas there is who came in for the
kiss finished from behind yep oh there's
a timer all right buddy oh yeah we're
gonna stick together here oh what Oh
cover oh yeah cover on there you go I
use that dodge yeah John rule yeah
that's on the left bumper good Oh what
hope your man no any work on oh yeah no
I always got the shopping it up
everything you have to evening it up you
guys are gonna lose yeah by one kill 00
double night yeah cowards our hands I
game may be halted a little bit level
tats all she wrote although looks like
it's given the W to this guy oh this is
like a dramatic wind screen a sort of
thing they've got in place mm-hmm which
works really well if it's it like cuz
yeah I don't the time run out yeah yeah
alright yeah so it but if it's the last
kill then if you like actually see them
like their gun as art has just gone off
and it's not all it's cool how many
rounds is it Oh we'll find out
how come that guy's night kind of home i
don't know i think i need Kirby probably
right oh oh it's probably fired ooh nice
night though samba why isn't that dead
what's hard likely wrong that was great
great playwright the hunted boom my wife
is wrote a ton maybe like control it
with the other joystick oh you think i
wonder if crazy trying to find out watch
out for that will oh I'm gonna get to
shoot Oh three times and the shotguns
pretty disgusting cuz they want to kill
me boy yeah man it's a shocking how much
you got to shoot Gary times before after
we look oh yeah you're kind of limping
around I do it was hot pursuit
no chance in this guy now you guys
speaking enough have numbers we figured
out the most basic tenets multiplayer
shooters win the first shoot oh yeah or
this guy what is that guy doing see ya
wagon he's on a 56k modem dial 0 this
until I trying to get stuff lady just
along there there's a live Judum
shooting Chris run oh my god Superman
shot it is there goes a little hat
sombrero all right let's go so why
aren't you wearing a poncho their
secrets that's hidden under me
oh you gots like kind of stunned yeah
this poor guy right this is really
trying real hard oh like I need a real
oh please leave me alone have you played
as the heavy at all no the like Civil
War veteran dude sure i remember i
played this at e3 last year I didn't
plan this map I only played on hurry up
the one day we're showing but you're
definitely depending on what class you
play it changed your gameplay and
completely which is which I thought was
really cool but there's a heavy with
complete machine gun oh that kick the
heavier the big machine gun is not in
this build I don't think I was or at
least is not selectable from the very
beginning oh good ah yeah there we go
and we're talking I'm gonna shoot my
foot I mean that wasn't very well you
cared welcome results pretty solid I see
tho except University both build about
the same damage yeah you just gotta
finish it on I just got the time and
attention alright we have time for
something you should try character let's
check it out alright hug Oh your thug so
you can clears like customization like
as I my bounty went up now I can do on
them both in damage here air I'm sure go
for a damaged cuz often a good defense
is a great is and then they're gonna be
skins which are not quite in yet um
let's switch oh and you're worth a
thousand you want to always do so this
is yeah this is the killer this is kid
red who I chose there's dual pistols and
then a throne dynamite gorilla the
deserter has the rifle which is pretty
high damage but is also pretty slow its
long-range and then a medikit like this
is the only character i think they can
heal and there's the one we just were
fighting against the phantom poncho the
shotgun with the bullwhip so maybe we'll
try just to see which one you wanna see
I'm like in the ER to the desert
the deserters are easiest one to play is
what they told me when I played it easy
sounds good to me well the medkit
probably helps a lot that's why Yeah
right so what do you guys have like you
have like perks to put stuff into do you
go to like offset the stuff that you are
weakened or do you try to like stubble
down on what you are good at I I think
it depends I mean offsetting already I'd
of the fire right with this guy I went
up the fire right and there's like AI
would have time offsetting is pretty
good his rifle is a little bit slower so
so I think Matt I was helping him out
even zip giving him a little bit more of
a little speed to like what like put
down the muskie like pull out the powder
foot in the powder bottle it in get the
tamping in there get then that was
pretty solid you feel you seem like you
have some experience below to like do a
Civil War reenactors like a junior high
thing no yeah not in San Diego you did
not know was that Mel Gibson movie
Patriot know that is it the Patriot
Revolutionary War ya know but this which
know that they said you still had to do
the muskie yes yes you just remember the
one part slow-motion the tomahawk all
right before right after the tomahawk
yeah because he had the his sons bullet
or the son's toy that he melted down
that made a bullet out of yeah that was
the one he used but then I nicked them
in the shoulder Nick the bag Lynn how
dare you call me a dirty kill stealer by
the way these are people in the
twitch.tv / gamespot chat slandering my
name but really if it's team deathmatch
kill stealing is a selfish person's mind
set II
you just try to kill the person until
they're dead that's my take on the
matter I don't know what you guys think
you let someone have their kill like is
that even if they're looking like
they're going to close to have like low
health I don't know in this game well
yeah I didn't think you did anything
wrong fact in other games in other games
I think it's very clear like okay that
guy's definitely gonna kill him but then
look I got you yeah yeah like I there's
the games where you can like shoot
someone who's in the middle being melee
attack by another teammate that's what
vexes me it's like look I'm literally
going through the unskillful laminate
animation of cutting out their trachea
you had to shoot him with a shotgun I
got this oh do you yeah go stealing cuz
every time I play with my friends it's
like man I got another assist it's like
you got the last bullet didn't you yeah
I'm probably good I lost statistics not
hey you were five hundred dollars that's
pretty good considering you not that I
meaning so it's a little glimpse at the
other modes that are gonna be available
in the game you got one b1 to b2 and for
before death matches to v2 and 44
domination all right looks like we're
gonna buy nobody feliz 0 double that guy
double knife guy killer it's a large
knife more like a saucer the pic yeah it
looks more like almost liking on one of
those knives you have all rights in
German this is quite the contrast of sub
lead man
your range hasn't seemed very much
further yeah this the spread looks the
sprays do you wanna hear a large spread
just take a listen Oh your second use a
mid-pack either yeah but your name oh
thanks dad walk up to them 10 pier jump
for those yeah it looks like there's a
ramp but nope not able to get there it
is hello oh wait of a lot right it's cuz
my med pack motto kicked in no you and
help you're just stunned from the note
okay Houston every load can you will use
I make it once or something they're
closed doesn't look like it damn it
that's why why what time is it though I
think yeah I would take the med pack all
day psupero penis so yeah but they could
technically kill you if they cough boy
right seafield long-range person though
yeah right like I can be taken out you
know that guy did it really is hard into
poncho
selling both landed that's how anxious i
found me but is slowing the only up for
more below ceiling unlimited so this
dude has no dodge ability of any guy oh
really yeah doesn't well just take it
just came for the kid yeah my any
brother finally kidding gonna take the
damage from the kid range this guy sucks
I'm not working the yellow face you have
you gotta use paper Gotti's cover you
have more range than you played at math
yeah but you can't this one you can just
do you can't like stop and pop out of
cover yeah but you can stick behind
cover right go Junior oh there you go ha
you just got to get close that's how
that you did though just kitem there it
is nice and it should just really
tighten back with this whole time that's
what his teammate
do that quickly there you go hold on
guys I'm just gonna take my box up does
he do it like again right away look down
by going
look he looks quick you know so you
could close that gap
oh that guy though yeah react was not
good work I feeling like I'm not
character it's so like that yeah I did
well I definitely did not figure out
that character the first time through
but cuz I feel like like when you hit on
unless it's because you're not hitting
it like all three bullets it doesn't
even seem to be doing that much damage
you are it almost looks better to use
the phantom guy with the shotgun mm-hmm
cuz I shouldn't like the range is not
that yeah but he has a different ability
though right Pharaoh like I did a lot of
day 685 yeah there's Jim I'm used to
having the the nimbleness cuz I played
as the kid and I've played as the killer
and they both have a dash ah so phantom
guy look like he hadn't and and then go
so good oh maybe we'll give it more try
once you use it of the kid since you all
right and then we'll uh real tool
players yep yeah i'll show you got some
kid what did you put your points into
our region is that even good is there a
budget damage was there a stamina bar ah
there is this the sort of stamina stuff
um this is kid with like 80s um there
isn't like a cool down for the sphere
like dash or whatever but not sure where
it is on screen to be honest cause is
pretty fast little did we know was that
three clock to him
right oh yes yeah plus we hit the three
o'clock time which the developers were
saying is the better time to try to get
into multiple player matches I like your
kid red we're good and read because
originality and navy is what we're super
good at all right so got to avoid the
whip the sword toss is not really that
like I'm talking to you though didn't it
did it definitely did Oh at least you're
getting different levels so this is the
third level this is the one I played on
before I think it packs bunch of caskets
oh man your way fast oh you know what I
forgot to do is tap wait is tap Barbie
so what's that circle that's a kind way
as you can tell chris's place is scary
Oh comfort yeah I'm feeling a little
better with that one oh you can't escape
me quick shoot down nasty kids oh so you
have the dynamite Factory stammers yeah
I just spamming ready alright kill the
other guy one we love oh oh nicely done
by the Phantom so the Phantom like
disappears to see them like disappearing
you you not sure if that's just like cuz
I'm not sure if the killer also did that
and it's just a matter of like the dash
being a little weird or if it's okay
let's focus on not sure if it's a bug or
feature just going off again
oh that guy's got a lot of life oh you
got back up oh just kidding wow he got
wasted what do you seem like the killers
are shot hey faster than when we were
watching trishy unless as the kids gonna
I mean like I said I didn't die yeah Oh
like that see he did like you know your
classic oh I am Ravi that dog hollering
stuff Oh get him all right amigo it's on
abduct before he went invisible I don't
know if it's just ducking behind things
makes you go invisible
yes it's hiding behind things that makes
you go invisible don't like a lion
sighting yeah their way
oh really ha no bailing there's no
mailing okay no nice well done so when
you do the double shop it's tons on huh
yeah so there's a quick for the single
shot is longer range right oh yes yeah
which gives out ranges that kid Oh
what's up kid that a win both think it's
like a half time cuz wasn't there aren't
there two R end of the round yeah cuz we
don't we haven't seen you don't see the
scoreboard necessarily all right all
right all right here we go the kids yeah
round two you got a verdict
ah man oh good god ice Munson Oh chef
for that whip oh nice oh yeah yeah yeah
the key oh hello
shocker and it's not bread and what
season were there
like all usually heat-treated lives
really Oh
okay a little bit of spawns bugs to work
out still you're like the dynamite I
can't go time in the walk yeah
we like yeah you got all came to get
mm-hmm sometimes it can be good if you
could have throw it back up so they can
change getting reload a bit is also can
be good if you're getting pursued right
so it's either you lay it near you or
you gonna shock reload in emissions
trial that was a mistake came into it
that was a mistake interposing oh y'all
the last bullet one in the chamber oh
wow I just got too close because I
wanted to go for the stun and then
that's the shotgun range oh good kill I
got yeah you did kid with a DS actually
at six
oh you guess is a good match back and
forth yeah nine seconds hey on top oh
this is done God with a double stun this
is both of us this was me about to
pursue my shots on the old man that was
a close match yeah yeah Robin from Teen
Titans oh yeah it is so yeah I like the
kid a little better a little bit a
little bit a little bit i think we
headed did what 200 damage seriously so
come here oh i can only walk forward and
shoot you spend and deliver alright so
that's secret ponchos glad we finally
got to get to take a look at that thanks
to the developers secret monkey for
giving us the tip how we you're messing
it up you guys can get into that on
early access right now just don't try to
get into a match on the same IP as a
friend of yours until they update that
that's available on Steam and as are
those other games we saw some nidhogg we
saw some star wall in there as well
multiple players favorites all thanks
Eric max Julio for joining me yeah
absolutely awesome fun times guys
tomorrow morning adil at the left alone
Daniel do are subbing in for the Sean
method to play some far cry blood dragon
and then the lobby is back live tomorrow
Tuesday at two p.m. we got some good
games we've got some good jokes maybe
like that at least one of them will see
you guys there thanks for watching
multiple players will catch you later
you